Hallo Leute. Diese Woche begrüßen wir euch aus Norwegen. Hier sind wir für eine Woche.
und besuchen verschiedene Schulen und heute haben wir einen Tag frei
und machen einen kleinen Ausflug.  Wie ihr wisst, immer wenn wir ein bisschen Zeit haben, nehmen wir "Cari antwortet" auf
und jetzt beantworten wir wieder eure Zuschauer-Fragen!
Guck mal, Janusz, ist das nicht schön hier?
Guck mal, hier sehen wir schöne Inseln mit Ferienhäusern.
Wir fangen an mit euren Fragen.
a.m. schreibt (auf unser Video "At the German Bakery"):
a.m., du bist ziemlich der Hammer,
denn das ist krass, dass du das noch wusstest. Also ich würde mal sagen, du bist unser Zuschauer des Jahres, jetzt schon,
weil du einfach gewusst hast, dass ich vor sieben Jahren in einem Video gefragt habe, warum das Amerikaner heißt?
Du hast dir das einfach gemerkt und das wussten nicht mal wir!
Ich habe gestern laut gelacht, als ich das zum ersten Mal gelesen habe, und Janusz auch, und Isi wird sicherlich auch lachen.
Danke für diesen Hinweis!
Das haben sehr viele Leute geschrieben. Guck mal da, wunderschöne Insel, Janusz. Ist die nicht schön?
Also, viele Leute haben geschrieben in unserem Video bei der Bäckerei. Da haben wir so komisch langsam gesprochen, das stimmt, denn wir wollten eigentlich
ein "Super Easy German"-Video machen, also ein langsames Video, deshalb fängt das Video langsam an.
Das Problem ist, dass der Bäckermeister so schnell gesprochen hat, und auch mit Berliner-Dialekt, dass wir eigentlich
nicht weitermachen konnten mit "Super Easy German", deshalb wird einfach normal gesprochen, also jetzt ist es einfach ein Mischmasch. Tut mir leid.
Cari falsch geschrieben mit K ;)
Ich weiß nicht, was du meinst, aber
also ich soll nur auf Deutsch sprechen... tue ich ja.
also wahrscheinlich meinst du, ich soll die Fragen, die auf Englisch kommen auch auf Deutsch vorlesen, aber ich lese die halt so vor, wie sie kommen, weil
warum auch nicht. Und wenn du vielleicht meinst, dass ich zwischendurch englische Wörter benütze, oder jemand anders,
darüber haben wir schon öfters Beschwerden bekommen, aber das ist so. Also man muss auch Sprache so nehmen, wie sie ist, und
Sprache ist beweglich und
flexibel und die verändert sich und
das ist so, dass wir im Deutschen  englische Wörter benützen, wie in ganz vielen Sprachen. In vielen Sprachen übrigens noch viel mehr als in Deutsch, aber
Englisch ist halt global und wir benützen alle Englisch irgendwann.
Auf diese Frage kann ich dir sagen "jein", also
es ist kein Tabuthema in dem Sinne, dass man das nicht ansprechen darf. Ich glaube, dass viele Deutsche da
viel darüber lernen und auch darüber sprechen wollen, das ist gar keine Frage, aber es ist natürlich
trotzdem ein unangenehmes Thema, also
das ist ja so, wenn jetzt in deiner Familie irgendwie
dein Opa irgendwen ermordet hat, dann ist das jetzt auch nicht das Thema,
was man jetzt gerne jeden Abend bespricht, ne?
Also es ist schon (ein) schwieriges Thema aber ich glaube, dass die Deutschen sich ziemlich bewusst darüber sind
und sich sehr intensiv damit auseinandergesetzt haben und auf jeden Fall darüber sprechen, also
wenn du das ansprichst bei jemandem, werden die kein Problem damit haben,
und werden dir bestimmt auch alles beantworten dazu, aber natürlich werden sie das jetzt nicht
wenn man irgendwie eine nette Zeit miteinander verbringt, ist das nicht das erste Thema, was man jetzt gerade auf den Tisch bringt. Das ist ja,
kann man wahrscheinlich verstehen.
Ja Donald, das freut uns.
Dann würde ich sagen, mach doch mal ein Video für uns. Schick uns das mal.
Poste das. Poste mal ein Video. Wir wollen sehen, wie du tanzt.
Unbedingt.
Deutsche Männer stecken immer das Hemd in die Hose, sogar T-Shirts auch.
Stimmt, und sogar polnische Männer machen dass auch. Janusz macht das auch, und ich mache mich immer darüber lustig. Stimmt nicht. Janusz zeigt mir so.
Janusz zeigt mir einen (Vogel?). Janusz sagt,
er steckt nie das Hemd in die Hosen. Doch, machst du! und zwar wenn du
dich anziehst. Hinterher machst du es dann wieder raus. Als Beweis zeigt er jetzt, macht er gerade seine Jacke auf, und ich soll das jetzt wahrscheinlich
ein Video davon machen, also ich mache jetzt ein Video wie
Janusz sein Hemd zeigt. Guck mal, das ist Janusz.
Aber guck, mache mal das Hemd hoch. Guck mal. Darunter ist ein T-Shirt in der Hose, ja? Jetzt holt er es wieder raus.
Also François, du hast Recht. Du hast etwas beobachtet, was typisch Deutsch ist, was noch niemandem vor dir aufgefallen ist.
Genau, Jean François, genau.
Janusz, ist das nicht geil hier?
Genau so habe ich mir Norwegen immer vorgestellt, Leute. Genau so. Guck mal da Janusz! Kannst du da mal ganz kurz rübergehen?
Ist das nicht Wahnsinn?
Ich muss jetzt....ich muss schnell ein Foto machen. Hammer. Zu unserem Video "What's typical German"...
Ja, wer von euch denkt das noch? Schreibt's uns mal in die Kommentare!
Danke für diesen Kommentar. Wir sind immer noch in einem Fjord in Norwegen und die nächste Frage, oder der nächste Kommentar kommt von...
Martina Bulgarieva, die übrigens aus Bulgarien kommt...
Wo fahren wir gerade hin?
Das stimmt. Ich war noch nie in Bulgarien aber ich bin gerade in Norwegen!
Wir sind immer noch in einem Fjord in Norwegen und unsere nächste Frage ist von...
also es ist eine Aussage...
(Hat) mir sehr gut gefallen, der Kommentar.
Das stimmt, Jawad. Als mir das ausgefallen ist,
dass das typisch Deutsch ist zu sagen, dass man nicht typisch Deutsch ist, habe ich selber auch damit aufgehört zu sagen, dass ich typisch Deutsch bin, weil
genau das will ich ja nicht sein. Ich will ja nicht typisch Deutsch sein, und wenn es typisch Deutsch ist, dass man sagt, man ist nicht typisch Deutsch,
dann will man natürlich das nicht weiterhin sagen, dass man typisch Deutsch ist, weil sonst wäre man ja typisch Deutsch, also habe ich natürlich damit aufgehört.
Danke nochmal für den Kommentar.
Seht ihr, Janusz, da unten im Spiegel? Das ist Janusz.
Janusz, was sagst du dazu? Also Janusz (hat) ist das auch passiert in den USA und die Kassiererin (also er ist derjenige, der gerannt ist)
Die Kassiererin hat sich geweigert, ihn anzunehmen. Du hast recht, ähm...
dass es typisch Deutsch ist, Ordnung zu bewahren, aber es ist auch natürlich typisch Deutsch, immer der erste sein zu wollen,
deswegen in diesem Fall "clashen" diese beiden Dinge
Hier sind wir jetzt am sogenannten Pulpit Rock, "Preikestolen"
und dieses Ding, das ragt 600 Meter
aus dem Wasser heraus und ist eins der bekanntesten Wahrzeichen Norwegens, wie ich mir habe sagen lassen.
Also es ist sehr bekannt. Ihr fragt euch sicher, warum wir in Norwegen sind
und der Grund dafür ist, dass uns Susanne, eine Deutschlehrerin aus Norwegen, eingeladen hat,
einige Schulen zu besuchen. Sie unterrichtet nämlich Deutsch an einigen Schulen, und da fahren wir morgen hin nach Haugesund und auf die Insel Røvær
und da freuen wir uns schon wahnsinnig drauf, und ihr werdet dann auch einige Videos sehen aus unserem Workshop.
Ja Leute, das war's mit unserem Video heute. Wir haben wieder eure Fragen beantwortet. Wie ihr seht, ist es immer noch wunderschön hier
in Norwegen und wir werden noch ein paar Tage hier bleiben. Wir werden Schulen besuchen. Wir werden Videos für euch drehen
Seid schon mal gespannt, guckt rein auf unseren Kanal, und guckt, was es Neues gibt, und ähm...
schreibt uns unbedingt ein paar Fragen, also wir freuen uns auf eure neuen Fragen. Wir wissen, im Moment kommt "Cari antwortet" nicht
so regelmäßig, wie ihr euch das gerne wünscht und wie wir uns das gerne wünschen aber wir möchten es öfter machen.
und wir versuchen es immer, wenn wir unterwegs sind, machen wir neue Videos. Schreibt uns eure
Fragen zur deutschen Sprache und Kultur
und werdet gerne Patreon bei uns. Wir freuen uns über jeden, wirklich jeden, der uns unterstützt. Wir haben Kontakt zu vielen
von euch. Wir haben eine tolle Facebook-Gruppe, und das ist einfach ein wahnsinnig tolle "Support". Das könnt ihr hier werden, könnt ihr Patreon werden.
Danke. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Schickt uns mehr Fragen!